now I don't even know where to begin
I've seen so many child soldiers that
couldn't have been more than 10 or 11
years old in uniform and with guns I've
seen little children raped and and as if
that wasn't enough by many men and as if
that wasn't enough their legs were
pounded into pulp afterward you know we
I come away from some of these trips
with huge existential questions about
who we are as human beings and how we
have to be more alert and aware of our
own components as human beings we have
the capacity to do wonderful things and
help each other and we have the capacity
to do terrible things to each other and
to acknowledge that we have that those
components own them and take
responsibility for them I mean this is
huge and I feel that you know as a
parent a single parent of my own
children that you know if every parent
and every human being
just says you know yes you know the
enemy is also me and I accept that I can
do terrible things I am capable of doing
terrible things and I'm also capable of
doing immense good in this world and
helping others and it's a question of
decision and weeding out those
components that are less worthy to be
the person we need to be